today lance mccullers jr will be back on
the mound for houston
yeah the opponent batting average is
good at 167 so you're probably wondering
why the 5.27 era and that's mostly
because of nine walks this season
there's been a lot of traffic
when lance loses command so look for the
fastball command to hopefully be better
than this start
the year before yuli will flip to lance
mccullar's junior covering
so using the position numbers that is a
three to one
on the scoreboard one out nobody on for
shohei otani the designated hitter
gets the call outside corner mccullars
picks up his first strikeout
ohtani thought it was off the plate yeah
blantz gets this strike zone today
it will really benefit him credit
martine maldonado for getting this
strike with the back door breaking ball
two out nobody on for left fielder
justin upton batting 242
the count is full three and two to upton
hot shot left side
in the hole base hit so the angels get
something going with two outs
nine-game hitting streak for him now and
jared walsh will be
the batter with two outs and a runner-on
swing and a miss
got him with that curveball all eight of
his strikeouts against lefties this year
have been on the curveball lance picks
up
two strikeouts in the first inning bundy
on the mound
look beyond the 0-2 record he's pitched
effectively this year
k-rate is the highest he's had in his
career hard hit is the lowest he has had
in his career
and that ball sliced the other way
justin upton will
watch it bounce off the base of the wall
he's going to need help from his infield
brantley will hold up at second base
that ball really
shot off the base of the out of town
scoreboard walling left
another double for michael brantley
that's four in a row in the last four
beds
a doubles machine this season michael
brantley
hits it hard left side it's gobbled up
by rojas that's a couple of fine plays
in this
series it's a two outs runner at second
and the batter will be alvarez
next pitch and that is a breaking ball
looked like it might have been a little
bit outside but it's a called third
strike
and that will wrap up the innings
three three ball counts out of the first
five hitters as pujol sends one into
center field straw moves to his left
puts it away that'll be the first out
scott schedler will be the next batter
schedler's been filling in for mike
trout in this series in center field
oh there's a nice play by diaz we're
gonna have to
show that one on the scoreboard diaz is
like how did i
catch that that ball was really crazy
off the bat i was gonna say it
was almost an inside out type movement
to that
this would be a great visual same thing
if
robel garcia at second is on the
shortstop side i'll put a little six in
parentheses on top of
the four as alex bregman makes the play
that's a 5-3 to end the inning lance
mccullers jr
very efficient with a nine pitch second
inning you have a lot of guys getting
their opportunity
playing positions behind you and
struggling in a very deep
tough division breaking ball went out
and got it
off the end of the bat here comes justin
upton on the run
went in with the fastball that one
driven toward the gap in right center
field
on the run schedler hauls it in that's a
great route by schedler he can play
all three outfield positions runs that
one down he says yeah i got it no
problem
mike trout i know you can get to that
baseball as well and he's playing a more
so
left center
that one's popped up foul is it playable
maldonado and lance giving a long run
and maldi puts it away
lance is right there just in case aldi
with the platinum hair
making the play in the top of the third
no score of the pitch
it's a ground ball to the shortstop diaz
he waits on it now got it
and throws to first base in time to get
fletcher by a couple of steps and that's
a one two three
for mccullers trying to get that strike
zone expanded here's the next pitch and
that's a swing and a miss
and he got him easily right there miles
straw the top of their order will step
up
outside corner that's not a number
that's a letter that's a k
and you put it backwards in your
scoreboard two out of three strikeouts
looking on the ground with the shift in
play
the only one on the left side is alex
bregman and
you knew you had to be a little bit
aware of ohtani going
into left field brantley going back to
the track he will put it away at his hip
for the final out of the inning
dylan bundy on the hill fourth inning
scoreless game this angle in this
ballpark really tells the story of what
you're
talking about for that breaking ball by
the way
that's strike three and it's been a
strike all day long second time
alvarez caught looking back door
breaking ball
yeah you can understand the frustration
he knows the strike zone for young
hitter
so here is guriel with two quick outs
the next pitch
and that is a called third strike on the
outside
corner and another sinker just like that
crossing generations like albert pujols
has done
oh that's an off speed pitch and it got
him
looking like a change up jose iglesias
this man is right he's a pretty extreme
ground ball pitcher
there's a little roll or a ground ball
to maybe just what the doctor ordered
for the angels
he was thinking his best shot was second
base the angels have a pair
on with one out for jose rojas he's
fighting himself a little bit right now
let's see if the halos can take
advantage
pitch and that is a little high sinker
misses and that is ball four
so the angels have them loaded and you
look how the angels have
done it here in the inning a walk an
infield hit and a hit batter and now
we'll see
what happens with bim boom stepping up
here comes the 2-2
strike three call on the outside quarter
another hook
boom checked his swing again but again
it didn't matter
this ought to be fun here because fletch
can handle that breaking ball away and
this is not a match-up at all that
mcculler's wants this is like a nat
buzzing around you right now
little roller right side hugs the line
hits the bag
everybody's safe another run come on
down
save at the blade having let's get two
rbis
boy oh boy the magic of david fletcher
right there
a line hugger up the first base side it
smacked off the bag
and then ricocheted over the head of
guriel who tried to
grab it with his hand and boy what a
lucky break the angels
really haven't had one all series until
that one it's two nothing
two to halos upton oh that's pretty
up into this backing out of the batter's
box on that slider and he gets called
out for
lance mccullars four strikeout love to
get through the sixth inning here
getting settler he does strikeout number
five for lance mccullers jr
so they've got their first two on here
gregman will be
the next batter fastball on the hands
rolled out to rojas
on to first
angels turn that one and that'll do it
alvarez is on first base
there's guriel he's over twos flight out
to left field and struck out here's the
pitch and it's hit pretty well
good one left field we're tied
guerrielle does it again a two-run
shot just a little too far up in the
zone and yuli ready to rake
pulls the hands in barrels it up and
shoots the astros into a tie game
he got two winning to get it done joey
otani leading off here
top of the eighth inning trying to get
some offense going and here's the next
pitch and shohei ohtani lifts a high fly
ball this one is carrying deep out into
center
field it's out of here show time
as ohtani connects that's home run
number seven of the season forum
that's a club high right now and cho hey
has given the angels a
3-2 lead that baseball is crushed
well not the sprint around the bases
that time you have to stop
and watch and admire how far this goes
shohei the power wow
because that swing gives the halos a
lead
mike trout siding mike trout siding you
have to for that swing don't you
he's in scoring position for bim boom
with one out so here's bim boom batting
and he swings at the first pitch and
lines that one into right field let's
see if rojas will be waved around he
will be
the throw will be cut off he'll score
and
boom his first rbi of the season
gives the angels a 4-2 lead closer
for the halos reisel iglesias had a
tough one on friday
two of four in save situations
hot shot could be two back cannon flip
on to first albert did you stay
on he did
back to their winning ways the angels
hold on a little bit of a high wire act
to end things